Once you've checked off these tasks, I've got these questions for you.
There's a library being used whose name starts with a U,
what's that library called?
What's the name of the organizational library being used to
separate our concerns?
How many views do you see in this application?
And this last question, isn't a question, it's a statement.
Only check this check box, when you do feel comfortable moving on.
If you need to play with the application more, do it.
If you need to explore the file structure or look at what java script files
are loaded, or figuring out what these libraries do.
If you need to do any of that, do it now, before you move on.
Once you do move on, I'll go through these, and I'll tell you what I see.